germany's social democrats have voted to
back a coalition agreement with the
greens and free democrats
the coalition is expected to be led by
the spd's olaf schultz the greens and
the fdp still need the final seal of
approval from their members schultz
could be sworn in as chancellor as early
as next week the so-called traffic light
alliance will end 16 years of leadership
by angela merkel and is expected to
focus on digitalization and fighting
climate change
[Applause]
and dw correspondent nina hasa has been
following this crucial sbd party
congress for us nina more than 98 of the
party's members have voted for this new
coalition deal that's a pretty clear
mandate isn't it
that is a pre a pretty clear mandate but
it was expected there was a bit of
criticism here and there from some of
the spd delegates who said that there
were too many compromises
especially when it comes to how the sbd
signed the treaty when it comes to the
partnership with the greens and the fdp
so the business focused fdp but overall
all the delegates said that they
supported this coalition treaty because
of course they want to see olaf schwarz
in the chancery and then olaf schultz uh
again asked
his delegates also to give the approval
for this coalition treaty he said it's
time for renewal of this country that he
needs to become the chancellor of
renewal he sees himself in the tradition
of the spd's famous chancellors from the
1970s willie brand and helmut schmidt
and says that he wants to be re-elected
in four years time but of course he also
laid out his top priorities for the
coming months and above all he mentioned
fighting the climate change and fighting
the covet pandemic let's listen to what
he had to say
escaped this is not about us it's about
the citizens of this country
it's also about huge challenges some on
a global scale if we consider human-made
climate change
but let me also say this
the first and most important challenge
we need to tackle is one that has been
uniting us for almost two years a task
that we all face together
and that is protecting the health of our
citizens keeping the country together
combating the coronavirus pandemic with
all of our strengths
and that is also our first task
so nina we just saw olaf schultz uh
addressing the party members what were
some of the other highlights that we
might need to know about
well of course olaf schwartz stressed
the unity of his party which is not
something that the social democrats are
really famous for for a long period
there was a lot of infighting but then
they managed to win this election also
by portraying olaf as sort of the
natural successor to angela merkel the
outgoing chancellor with his aura of
merkel-esque stability so this was
something that they were very proud of
that they managed to keep it together
but now of course many people fear that
there are a lot of
issues in the way especially when it
comes to the compromises that
the new government is going to have to
make because of the different interests
from all the three different partners
that are in this coalition with the
business focused fdp blocking some of
the spd's um more social projects etc so
this is something where there are going
to be a couple of stepping stones to be
overcome
and you're mentioning that uh there are
some some big uh
you know divisions between the coalition
uh
party members big splits over money and
so on uh but schultz is likely to be
sworn in next wednesday if he overcomes
those divisions he'll be taking over
from angela merkel in power for 16 years
seen as a source of stability in europe
so people will be looking to him
for what can we expect big changes
this coalition government is going to be
a very different one from the current
one i mean you have to remember that the
social democrats also form part of the
current government but as the junior
partner so now they are going to take
over as the lead party olaf schulz as
the chancellor and of course he has been
angela merkel's deputy and her finance
minister for the last three and a half
years so he has pla had plenty of
opportunity to watch merkel and to learn
from her successes but also from her
mistakes but um what's different
is definitely that the party does have a
much bigger say here in germany than in
other countries uh for example if you
compare it to france where the president
can pretty much determine the agenda
here in germany the chancellor very much
depends on the support from the party
base and so this is something where
we're going to definitely see a
different a more center-left sort of a
government here in germany
okay dws nina has at the spd
headquarters thanks so much